TOM GRINSTED: Hello, everyone.
I'm Tom Grinsted.
I'm Group Product Manager
for Mobile Devices
at "The Guardian."
I'm also really, really aware
that I'm the final lightning
talk in the final session
of the day, so I'm
going to make it as lightning
as possible because, you know,
drinks.
So I'm really going
to talk about how
we've tried, especially in the
apps team over the last year,
to introduce some new ways
of working to really unlock
the creativity that's
embedded in development
teams themselves.
It seemed quite a long
time for the industry
in general, and to be frank,
the publishing industry
specifically, to
understand that development
is a creative process
in and of itself,
and teams of developers
and designers
have really creative ideas.
And the toss for us is to
really try to unlock them.
Now there are loads of different
ways to try to unlock ideas
and to try to get features
out to the public,
and there are loads of different
ways to plot them as well.
But for the sake
of this talk, I'm
going to plot them along
two different axes.
So along the x-axis,
then you've got
kind of self-led
creativity-- ideas
that you come up on
you own, yourself,
and you try to happen.
And at the other end,
you've got imposed
creativity-- stuff that's
given to you by other people.
And then along the y-axis,
we've got business return.
So you've got features that when
they're eventually deployed,
give really, really high value
to the business and high value
to your users.
And it's worth saying those
two things are essentially
synonymous, and you've got
things that are low value,
so either that
nobody uses or that
don't help the business at all.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to look at a few different
ways that we work
and how they plot along
these different axes.
So what would be a good
example of the top right?
Well, strategic features, right?
If they're strategic
features, they
might be very, very
high value because it's
aligning to the entire
strategy of your business,
and they're also likely to be
imposed because the business is
saying, team, I really
need you to do this.
In our case, it might be, team,
I really need you to get many,
many more users
signed into the app.
Then you've got
things like backlogs.
Now I'd argue the
backlogs, the tend
towards being slightly
more self-creative
because developers, especially
in functioning agile teams,
can go and pick up
cards that they think
are really important.
But they do tend
towards being imposed.
People like me help
kind of shape backlogs.
Then you've got bad ideas.
Bad ideas they
tend towards being,
well, especially bad ideas
from senior management--
I'm admitting to this-- impose
creativity at a low value.
We really need to do this, team.
Crap, it's failed.
Then you've bugs and debt.
Now, I was trying to
decide where to put this.
So our teams at "The
Guardian" are really
enabled to genuinely care about
the quality of their products,
and they pick up individual
bugs, individual pieces
of debt, add them
when they think
it's really, really important.
Now individually, they tend
towards being low value.
Although I don't want
you guys to think
I'm not saying that
quality is important.
Quite the opposite--
quality is critical.
Taken together, they might
be all the way up there.
But if you look at them
on an individual basis,
they're comparatively
low quality,
but they're slightly
more self-led.
Now, the next we're going
to look is hack days.
Keep your hands up if you
know what a hack day is?
OK, so not huge numbers.
Keep you hand up if you've
participated in a hack day?
OK, roughly the same
number of numbers.
OK, so a hack day
is where you get
loads and loads of developers
into a room together,
and you say, go away and build
something and demo at the end.
So it's kind of in some
ways the purest example
of self-led creativity.
Now, sometimes hack day
projects are hugely valuable.
In fact, "The Guardian"
has an internal suite
of analytics called Ophan,
which is phenomenal.
It's fantastic.
That grew out of one
of our hack days.
But very often-- so
it's worth saying,
that would be all
the way up here.
But very often,
hack day projects
don't align to
the strategic aims
because they're really an
opportunity for developers
to go away and play.
Sometimes they're
an amazing idea,
but they don't have enough
resource behind them,
and they can't do
because of other things
the business is doing.
Sometimes, frankly, they're
just trying to the crowd.
So sometimes hack idea ideas
are very, very high value.
But very often
than not, hack days
have a low hit rate for long
term value to the business.
Now by this way I'm talking
about feature specific.
There are loads of other
really, really good reasons
to do hack days-- giving
your developers a chance
to work together.
It's a fantastic tool to
get people who never talk
to each other actually talking.
But if you're being brutal
about just single features,
hack days, in and of
themselves, aren't long enough
and aren't focused enough
to have a consistent return
for the business.
So for me, the key question
is, what can fit here?
Can you construct
a way of working
which is both very
high value, unleashes
the creativity of your
development teams,
and has a really good
return for the business?
And for us, the thing that
fits in that question mark
is the build week.
Now, the build week,
as you my guess,
is a bit like a hack day,
but instead of just hacking
something together as quickly
as you can just to demo it
to an audience, you
built it, and you
build a to point where
it's in principle testable.
Instead of being a
day, it's a week.
And the reason it's a week
is that gives our development
teams and engineers
and UX designers
enough time to actually
build something which
is really, really compelling.
But like a hack day, it
unleashes their creativity
by giving a huge amount
of self-awareness,
so they really get to choose
what they're going to build.
And there area few rules to it.
The first in this important to
unleashing the strategic value,
is there's a strategic theme.
So ones that we've
run over the last year
have been about
mobile monetization,
around editorial innovation,
around key personalization,
and about making our apps
quicker and more responsive.
Solutions aren't imposed.
The job for someone like me
is to simply get the them,
and then allow the teams,
as large as they can be,
to get on and come up with
the most creative ideas they
can on their own to
try to meet that theme.
We take time at the
beginning of the build week
to deeply understand
what we're trying to do.
And critically, the
output is testable.
This needs to be
able to go somewhere
where we get actual
feedback from actual uses.
So this is an example of one of
the hack weeks we ran recently.
This is my lovely
team working on it.
It's worth pointing out that
the team isn't just engineers.
You've got Frank there.
He's a designer.
You've got [INAUDIBLE].
He's our mobile editor.
You've got Helen up there,
who's a UX researcher.
For our hack weeks we
try to make a team which
is as broad as possible.
Now, I said that one
of the key things
is the output is testable.
And I wanted to kind
of dwell a little bit
on what I meant there.
Because the idea of
build week is you're
coming up with tangible,
useful things for users.
So what do I mean by testable?
Well, at one end, you've
got testing in our UX lab.
Now, that's great,
but really what
we're looking for for build
week is something which can be
tested slightly further afield.
Then we've got
our alpha program.
Now, we use the alpha
program on Google Play
to do nightly builds
of our Android apps
that go out to any
of the internal users
within in "The Guardian."
And the alpha program
is a fantastic way,
at the end of a build
week, to test stability
across 600 users.
It's also great to get
stakeholders really excited.
There's nothing like
somebody suddenly
seeing a feature they
didn't know existed
for the first time that really
answers one of the needs
to get it rapidly
into production.
We also use a beta program.
And if you're interested in
signing up to the beta program,
you can follow that
url at the top.
Our beta program runs at
thousands of Android uses,
and we often take some of
the fantastic ideas that
come out of our build weeks
and whack straight into beta.
Or we also do staged
rollout MVT and A/B testing
in our live environment as well.
But the key point is
we're asking the teams
to spend one week deeply
understanding a problem
and coming up with the
most creative ideas
they can to solve
that, and the proving
if their ideas work or not.
[INAUDIBLE] provable?
Is this provably successful?
Do I have concrete examples
where this has worked?
It's quite telling
that when I was putting
these slides together, one
of the contacts in Google
kind of content and went,
shouldn't this be "probably?"
And I was like, no,
no, this is provably.
It's demonstrable.
So what are a few
examples, just to wrap up
where the build weeks have
really helped "The Guardian?"
Well, the first was
our hide-ads button.
So if you look at
the advertisement
on the right-hand side there.
That's a lovely
little hide button.
This grew out of our
mobile monetization week,
and it drives users to our
app free premium subscription.
Now when the developers
came up with this,
it seems like an obvious
idea, but because
of completely understandable
internal debate
within "The Guardian,"
we never got to the stage
where we were actually
rolling this feature out,
because ads and subs are, in
our app, mutually incompatible,
and they're two different
revenue streams.
Having this already built
as part of the build week
allowed us to test it
really, really rapidly
and come to the
discussions about
whether it was a good idea with
real, statistically relevant
data to inform the decision.
As you can guess, if any
of you use the Android app,
that decision was to deploy
it to life, because we did,
and it delivered a huge increase
in subs conversion rates.
Search and profile--
it was a [INAUDIBLE]
for personalization that
all of your read history
wasn't available, and
one of our developers
build this lovely set
of profile and search.
This went straight into the UX
labs, and it was loved so much,
we deployed it to live
within, I think, three weeks.
It's another kind
of one, for example,
it showed real
benefits for users
who are looking to go back
over articles that they've
read before.
So what's coming up?
In our personalization
build week
then one of the
developer's got together
with one of our
service side developers
and build a new recommendation
engine, which we're probably
going to call Discover.
This isn't live yet,
but it's probably
coming out this quarter.
It's the kind of investment the
business as a whole property
wouldn't have made
if it had been
asked to strategically
decide what
it was going to do initially.
But because it was
kick-started by the build week,
it's allowed us to
really, really rapidly
take into the alpha program.
Similarly, Read It
To Me-- Read It To Me
uses text-to-speech
engine in Android
to allow you to consume any
piece of "Guardian" content
without a screen.
What's really nice is as of
the build week last week,
it not only works on your
phone, but also interfaces
with ware, and now
interfaces with auto as well.
Now this is another one where
"The Guardian" as a whole
probably wouldn't
have spontaneously
come up with this because we're
so concentrated on the written
word, which is completely
understandable.
But by putting editorial
innovation, which
was the them of build
week to our engineers,
we came up with a feature
that we really, really hope's
going to substantially
increase engagement,
and it makes us happy.
These are my happy team.
So what's the takeaway that I'm
really suggesting to you here?
Now, those of you who've run
hack weeks, they're fantastic.
Those of you who run very, very
top-down development, that's
sometimes required
or needed, but there
is a fantastic middle ground.
That fantastic middle ground is
well describing in the problem
and allowing your teams
to go away and engineer
their solutions
and then test them.
So if you don't take
anything else away from this,
just try that out at
least once and see
what you get, because you
hopefully will be pleasantly
surprised, Thanks very much.